all right alongside Chris Taps porzingis
let's start off with your foot and know
you're resting at this summer planer
fasciitis how is it feeling are you able
to do full workouts yes I'm able to do
full workouts it's feeling great um
obviously a little bit setback and and
it hurt not being able to play with my
national team but uh I'm here uh full on
doing everything and and expected to
start off the season healthy want to get
to like the human element of being a
basketball player because we see so many
trades in the NBA but none of us as fans
are part of it
what was your reaction when you got
traded to Boston knowing you're coming
to this Contender no just extremely
excited extremely
excited understanding the opportunity
we're going to have here and uh there
was no uh second thoughts or anything
like that once I I um knew that this was
the opportunity this is exactly what I
wanted and I was very excited to to get
here and get the work you played with
other superstars like Melo Luca Bradley
be you know how have those situations
helped prepare you for playing with
Tatum and
brown definitely I mean you learn
something for every situation and and I
think what's the most important thing is
I see that these guys really want to win
it all you know and that's the main goal
here for them too and for the whole
organization and that's what
really that's what really I think makes
everyone excited and and and and just
ready to get to work and and yeah that's
I think all that experience I've gained
before it's going to help me with these
guys and just help the situation Drew
Holiday In the Mix now to are you ready
for these Championship
expectations I mean I'm here you know
we're going to we're going to get to
work
and and the expectations are High um
outside but of course also inside you
know and and we realize what what we
want to
achieve and it's going to be in our
hands do the daily work to get to that
end result but we have to focus on the
on the day-to-day tasks and and and then
we'll get there a lot of weapons on this
team offensively how do you fit
in I think it's going to be pretty easy
honestly um I think my game
complement uh JT and JB really well and
also the guys that we have I think
everybody's at a certain point in their
career where uh we're coming together
here for one
goal and that's going to make all of
that kind of process of you know playing
together it's going to make it so much
easier and so much more like okay this
is what we need to do and we're just
going to put our own stuff to the side
and and let's do this because we need to
do this and we're more effective doing
this and so on so so I think um
I think it's going to be sooner or later
we'll find it and and hit the um hit
that Rhythm and and we'll be fine